hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast cardiovascular disease
applying MRI to study atherosclerosis
the aortic arch and endothelial
permeability in small animal models
presented by dr. Claudia Cal Cal no
money I'm Chrissy jewel of Labatt's and
I'll be producing today's event today's
educational web seminars brought to you
by lab roots and sponsored by Brooker
Brooker enables scientists to make
breakthrough discoveries and develop new
applications that improve the quality of
human life
Rooker's high performance scientific
instruments and high-value analytical
and diagnostic solutions enable
scientists to explore life and materials
at molecular cellular and microscopic
levels for more information please visit
Brooker com
this presentation I'm about to show you
is broadcast live earlier today but I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive you may submit
questions at any time you like during
this presentation questions may also be
submitted during the on-demand period
and we encourage you to participate to
do simply type your questions into the
ask a question box and click on the send
button your questions will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen lastly at the end of the
presentation you will receive a poll
which we kindly ask you to complete your
answers and suggestions will help
improve our webinar program and it is
greatly appreciated our moderator today
will be Todd sasser's the head of
Brooker preclinical imaging applications
it is now time to enter the topic of the
day Todd over to you Thank You Christy
for a nice introduction and thank you
everyone for joining us today our
webinar today titled cardiovascular
disease applying MRR to study
atherosclerosis a Orta karch and
endothelial permeability in small animal
models is presented by dr. Claudia Cal
Konya dr. claudia calcio nia holds an MD
from the University of Genova and a PhD
from the ican School of Medicine at
Mount Sinai
her main research interest is dynamic
contrast enhanced MRI of atherosclerosis
arterial vessel wall
dr. Cal Konya you may begin your
presentation thank you so much Todd for
the nice introduction so as as Todd
mentioned I will be talking about
application of MRI to study
atherosclerosis
that means cardiovascular disease
specific focused on the quantification
of endothelial permeability
small animal models in this case a
federal schematic mice so first of all I
just wanted to give you a little bit of
background on why we would like to study
cardiovascular disease so as you can see
from the graph in this slide
cardiovascular disease due to
atherosclerosis actually cause of
morbidity and mortality worldwide and
that holds pretty much for all age
groups and and it surpasses even even
cancer in all age groups and there is
definitely a diagnostic and therapeutic
gap in cardiovascular disease even
individuals that are treated
aggressively with standard of care
optimize lipid lowering strategies such
as statins that you may have heard of
still have a very high residual
cardiovascular risk and there are
actually some individuals that was risk
cannot be adequately captured by
population-based risk scores so our goal
and a goal of many other researchers in
the field is to develop non-invasive
quantitative measures to better quantify
cardiovascular risk in these patients
and to better stratify them and let us
treat them and diagnose them in doing so
many people have been focused on trying
to diagnose basically what are called so
called vulnerable after discovering
plaques to try to identify these plaques
vulnerable across not a class or class
plaques at high risk for causing severe
acute clinical events that would be for
example heart attack and stroke and they
have a very well-defined histological
characteristics and among these the most
salient that we will sort of discuss in
this talk of the presence of
inflammation and the related presence of
leaky micro vessels and endothelial
and so enhanced endothelial permeability
in the clock so you can see for example
in this figure a schematic of the
progression of atherosclerosis and you
can see that for example an increase in
material permeability and endothelial
dysfunction a disrupted endothelial
barrier actually allow for the initial
lipid accumulation in implants later on
increase in material permeability an
extensive network of micro vessels or
neo vessels that form in the black
facilitate actually the extravasation of
inflammatory cells you can see here in
the middle that are basically recruited
after the maladaptive inflammatory
response that is triggered by lipid
accumulation itself so as I mentioned we
would like to develop quantitative
measures of these East illogical
correlates that would allow us to
identify and characterize vulnerable
high-risk a fellow's caloric plaques in
vivo and non invasively
in patients and focusing specifically on
endothelial permeability there are
several ways that this can be quantified
and investigated using magnetic
resonance imaging which is the focus of
our talk most methods that are used in
atherosclerosis are based on contrast
injection contrast agent injections so
the use of contrast enhanced MRI in our
case as this entails the injection of t1
shortening gadda lynnium based contrast
agents one possible strategy for
quantifying endothelial permeability is
the one that I show here in this slide
typically one image
at time zero before contrast Asian
injection is taken you can see one
example here of the an image taken
before contrast agent injection in an
atherosclerosis rapid where you really
don't see any announcement and then
contrast agent is injected a certain
amount of time typically passes and then
the same exact image is taken after
contrast agent injection at time T that
has to be predefined by the researchers
are may vary depending on the animal
model of the vascular territory that is
studied you can see in this case after a
certain amount of time there is the
images look a lot brighter which means
the contrast agent has extravasated in
certain tissues you can see for example
at the bottom right corner a zoomed in
image of the rabbit abdominal or that
looks a lot brighter with respect to the
pre contrast image and I'm just
exemplifying you know this process here
in this schematic you can see here in
gray some extra Sandra s traversal
extracellular space in a tissue these
dot these white ellipses are actually
cells the red dots are micro vessels in
the tissue and the bigger red line in
the middle is a feeding vessel of the
tissue you can see that the left side of
the tissues are represented with a
dashed line the endothelium in this case
it's permeable while the right side is
not permeable and in the schematics
after contrast you can see these small
black dots representing the contrast
agent in the vessel lumen extrapolating
in the tissue and also present in the
intra inside capillaries in the tissues
but not in cells because these contrast
agents that I've been talking about
today are actually extracellular and so
basically that is the the basics of the
process and
contrast agent uptake can be really
identified in measured in a couple of
different ways we can look as CH signal
enhancement which is basically what I
mentioned before the signal getting
brighter after the injection of contrast
with respect to before contrast agent
injection that you can find here in this
schematics another way to measure
contestation uptake is to actually
quantitatively measure changes in t1
relaxation time that are caused by
conversation injection in this case
because these agents are t1 shortening
agent we are going to be looking at a
shortening in t1 at a certain time T
after injection has it you know
schematically depicted here and these
are whether or not the only ways that we
can capture contrast agent uptake in the
tissue instead of simply imaging a time
t0 waiting and then imaging after
contrast at a certain time predefined T
we can keep on acquiring images before
during and after the injection of a
contrast agent and as depicted here we
can follow the kinetics of uptake of the
contrast agent in the tissue and this is
depicted in a similar schematic
representation that you saw in the
previous slide where you can see that
for example in the pre contrast
schematics there is no contrast agent on
the left side in the permeable tissue
immediately after or during conversation
injection a few contrast agent particles
sort of permeate the tissue and more and
more until we reach time T this approach
is called dynamic contrast enhance ml so
the approach that allows measuring the
uptake curve a contrast agent in a
tissue of interest
this is particularly useful to try to
calculate more quantitative parameters
that are for example as you can see in
this box - tissue permeability - the
fractional plasma volume in the tissue
and that would be basically the amount
of red dots that you have which would be
small vessels in each tissue or for
example the back flow flow from the
tissue to the plasma compartment and the
amount of extra vascular extracellular
space itself in the tissue which is
depicted here in gray that would be
typically lose matrix or connective
tissue right and if you were to look at
an uptake curve or counter stage in the
tissue of interest in overtime it would
typically look like this right with
concentration being I would say almost
basically at zero before injection and
then rising more or less rapidly
depended Li depending on the
permeability of the tissue plateauing
and then one step that I'm not showing
here sort of going going down the
contrast agent flows back to the plasma
compartment so this kind of curve can be
analyzed using modeling based approaches
which is kind of somewhat what I
described before but also non
model-based parameters such as the area
under the curve for example the uptake
slope would be in tailing taking the
slope for example from here to here all
the time to reach peak concentration and
so going specifically to atherosclerosis
a lot of work has actually been done to
develop quantitative Ammar based
measures of endothelial permeability in
atherosclerosis and and I am listing
here only three review papers that are
more obviously they constitute a good
it would starting point I think for a
literature search on this topic and a
lot of work has been done actually in
human patients with cardiovascular
disease especially in the carotid also
looking at East illogical validations
when these specimens were taken out for
carotid endarterectomy that was of
course performed as standard of care
intervention but also a lot of studies
are focused on on animals for example in
Africa Roderick rabbits and in mice in
this talk I will specifically focus on
some studies and some techniques that we
are developing to study and ethereal
permeability in mice so first of all why
would it be important to develop these
techniques in mice there are several
reasons one is that mice and the
obviously genetically manipulated
I wouldn't say easily but probably in an
easier way that other bigger animals to
create several disease models right
there are for example mice that are
after sclerotic clones but also diabetes
prone so that can be interesting to
study and they are a well-characterized
model of atherosclerosis and actually
more than one mouse model of
atherosclerosis exists they can be using
large scale studies because even
genetically modified mice are fairly
affordable in that sense or definitely
more than larger animals and they can be
investigated using sophisticated genetic
cellular and molecular assays that are
not so easily available on in larger
animals either because of cost reasons
or simply because they've not been fully
developed yet and and it this is
interesting to us because these are
cells can be a very good complement to
in vivo imaging either to tell us you
know something more about what we're
looking at with
ooh imaging or just as a ex vivo
validation or to better understand the
disease process so in the mouse
specifically we've been focusing on
studying the aortic root which you can
see here highlighted in a pre mice and
in multi b6 mice there is a behind
choosing the aortic root as a vascular
territory to study is that plaques
develop very reliably in this territory
they're typically quite permeable as you
can see here by the announcement and
extravasation of conversation in a
fluorescence image in this case and
unplugs in this territory acquiring
flames so the server purpose very well
so there are challenges otherwise in
imaging and the mouse erotic route for
example and you can see here the aortic
root is indicated by this red arrow
coming out of course of the upper left
ventricle and as you can imagine the
aortic root moves constantly with the
cardiac and respiratory cycle it's a
structure that especially in the mouse
very small in size and and so we are
talking about taking images of other
structures is very small and constantly
moves and we all know that typically in
an MRI this is very challenging and
requires the synchronization of imaging
with the cardiac and respiratory cycle
so the conventional strategy using
approaches that are triggered by
electrocardiogram signal which would put
actually electrode in a patient or a
mouse would be to image and acquire
basically a portion of the image portion
of case-based lines during a period of
time when the heart is fairly stationary
so that no motion artifacts make on time
images however implies the additional
problem so to speak and is that the
heart rate is really really fast I'm
indicating here three four hundred beats
per minute and this may vary of course
and it may be a little slower when the
mouse is under anesthesia and it may
vary a bit depending on how the
anesthesia is performed but in general
you know if the heart rate one goal I
would say down below 200 beats per
minute so of course the problem is to
acquire very high resolution images
being able to acquire only a few case
baseline per hour beats this takes many
many many heartbeats and so it's very
slow and this kind of imaging may not be
suited to capture the fast kinetics of
contrast agent entering the entering
class in the our C group so in order to
overcome these obstacles we have taken
and I'm showing here I'm sorry pretty
much the same concept where all the
different are beats a different portion
of k space would be acquired and then
all of these would be combined together
to obtain a full image of one cardiac
say it's basically one snapshot that can
be acquired either in systole or
diastole a slightly different approach
can be taken which can lead to more
efficient imaging and and that would be
for example to continuously acquire case
baselines regardless of basically detect
the cardiac phase in which these are
acquired the case baselines are acquired
continuously in a synchronous with with
the beating heart and then and some of
you may recognize this approach also
from clinical ml imaging and k-space
lines can be bend into specific cardiac
phases depending on the signal form for
example
ECG electrodes that may be in the mouths
or in the in the patient right to form
different card different images of
different phases of the heart so you
would see the heart moving across those
and however you know the ECG itself
especially for such an approach where K
lines are acquired continuously and
gradients are basically working almost
constantly I would say ECG approaches in
my high field as we are using are not
very effective because the the gradients
from the magnet themselves create
currents in the heart that distort the
ECG signal so it's very useful in this
small mouse model to actually use
self-guided approaches which I will go
into in a minute
and in this case Benning is basically
based on a on a navigator signal that
captures the cardiac and respiratory
cycle and doesn't need the use of any
external devices such as ECG electrodes
and I'm illustrating this concept in a
little more detail here where you can
see in this case applied to cardiac
imaging and not to packaging of the
aortic root you can see a navigator
slice that is placed actually at the
base of the heart where cardiac motion
can be detected but also respiratory
motion of course from the lungs and the
thorax and an imaging stack that is put
on the on the ventricle in this case and
the navigator slice is played before
every excitation as you can see here in
the past sequence diagram and and so if
it's a 1d signal that as you can see in
this following slide looks like this
after it's acquired and
that can be deacon volved pretty much in
a way the respiratory signal that you
can see here which is of course slower
and corresponds to these deeper down
world Peaks and in a way that cardiac
signal which is of course much faster
and corresponds to these faster peaks
and then typically what happens is that
case baselines that are acquired across
many cardiac cycles can be been bend
according to the cardiac signal that is
acquired by the navigator and to acquire
full images of course of different
cardiac phases and the approach is to
acquire the focal space matrix many many
times over many many heartbeats and
until a sufficient number of K lines to
fill each cardiac phase has been
acquired and the fact that there is no
heartbeat that is exactly the same as
the previous one or the or the next one
in terms of length there is always a bit
of a liability ensure that it is going
to be very unlikely that the same lines
keep on being acquired over over again
in the in the in the same phase of the
cardiac cycle so this is an intrinsic
pseudo-random filling that basically
ensures that after certain number of
cardiac cycles full images will be
acquired of all these phases and now I'm
going to show you a few examples of how
we have actually applied this method to
acquire quantitative images of
endothelial permeability in the mouth
our de Kloet I'm showing here a few
examples of a what I would call almost a
two chamber view not
because you can see here you're off the
route and not the mitral valve but of
the left ventricle you can see here the
left ventricle the our top bunching out
of it and the aortic root here you can
see a four chamber view of a mouse heart
you can see the left ventricle again the
aorta the aortic root right here and the
right ventricle here from these images
we can actually plan an axial slices
right through the our take root which
you can see here that's basically this
circle here in the middle and one thing
that I should mention that I have not
mentioned before and this is very
specific to vascular imaging typically
when we perform vascular imaging we use
so-called
black blood techniques if we want to of
course see the arterial that's a wall
and not the less illumine these are
specific MRI techniques that now the
signal from the blog post so that the
vessel wall can be easily seen and
interestingly in our case and as it has
been demonstrated before we can use the
same navigator that we used to [ __ ] a
space to actually also obtain a black
blood signal by simply varying the you
know the slip line slip angle of the of
the navigator which is what we actually
do here where we obtain bright blood
images with a certain flip n angle of
the navigator and black blood images of
the route in fact you can see in this
case the middle of the route is black
and you can faintly see the vessel wall
of the route in this black blood image
pre contrast and you can see delineated
a little better after contrast so we
have used this approach in several
flavors I would say to quantify interior
permeability in this territory
one of the approaches that we have used
which I mentioned before is actually
mapping of a decrease in the t1
relaxation time after contrast agent
injection we have taken an approach that
was actually published in NMR by
adenosine in 2016 to look at
permeability in the mouth myocardium and
we just adapted it to the mouths elastic
route and this approach consists
basically in acquiring a pre contrast t1
map using 3d imaging with variable slip
angles injecting contrast agent and then
following the update of contrast agent
in the aortic root using acquisitions
with only one flipped angle and from and
based on these equations that I'm
showing here you're going to be able to
basically calculate t1 at each point in
time after contrast agent injection and
get an estimate of the decrease in T 1
and therefore endothelial permeability
in this territory I'm showing here
examples of some images acquired pre
contrast and after contrast you can see
this is the images from the t1 map and
that was acquired pre contrast with as
you can see different different flip
angles so basically these images are put
together and based on the signal
equation of the specific sequence and
pre contrast 3 t1 relaxation time can be
calculated and these are images instead
acquire after contrast agent injection
you can see in fact the route indicated
by the yellow arrow and I'm saying
getting brighter and actually you can
see even the enhanced
decreasing a little bit as time goes by
because of contrast agent washout
from the route though by basically
normalization of the signal of each one
of each leave images to the previous one
we can calculate t1 post contest as you
can see here some preliminary results
actually from this data that were
presented this year at the is MLM
meeting in Paris you can see it simply
looking at signal-to-noise before and
after contrast doesn't really lead to a
meaningful difference between young and
old mice this is what the two bars
represent you can see that between young
and old mice the t1 pre contrast is
basically the same in this case I'm
actually mentioned as r1 which is 1
divided by t1 so if T 1 of course
decreases after contrast one divided by
t1 will increase and this is sometimes a
measure that is used because it's just
simpler I would say to talk about it
understand but you can see that the TDR
one post contrast is higher in older
mice with respect to younger mice
conversely of course the t1 would be
lower this indicates high extravasation
of contrast age and in older mice with
respect to your mice so higher
endothelial permeability and so is the
ratio of the r1 between post post and
pre contrast which basically again
indicates higher permeability in the in
the older mice so if you recall during
the introduction I said that our weather
data this is not just the only way to
calculate endothelial permeability we
can also use what we call dynamic
contrast enhanced MRI to try and follow
more closely with high
time resolution the contrast agent
uptake curve in the tissue of interest
so in this case that acquisition is
basically the same but we reckon struct
it a little differently so we would
acquire we could continue to acquire
constantly the same K space matrix over
time over many many cardiac cycles to
obtain as I said before different scene
images of of the heart in different
phases and on the route but during this
acquisition and in this case the
acquisition would have to be very long
maybe half an hour or more
we also inject a t1 shortening contrast
agent or if we want to reconstruct
images from this kind of acquisition
basically images acquired before the
injection of contrast will look like as
if there was no enhancement which is
what it should be and but as we inject
and has we reconstruct images not only
been by cardiac phase but also over time
we would see uptake of contrast agent so
this is an approach that we have
actually used to start developing a
dynamic contrast enhanced MRI of the
mouse optic route I'm showing here a
couple of examples of different kind of
reconstructions that can be you know
performed from such an acquisition and
typically this leads to a lot of
flexibility in terms of the number of
cardiac phases that can be reconstructed
and the number of temporal dynamics
frames that can be reconstructed I'm
showing here an example of images
acquired with eight cardiac phases and
only four temporal dynamic frames you
can see here a first image acquired
before contrast and then three images
acquired after contrast in this case the
acquisition was about thirty two minutes
so basically each one of these temporal
dynamic frames comes from eight minutes
of acquisition so of course this impacts
the signal-to-noise of the of the of the
images you can see here although of
course it's a lot smaller the same exact
acquisition and that is a weather
reconstructed with eight cardiac phases
the same number of CD images in the
heart but twelve temporal dynamic frames
you can only see you can see in this
case three click on test images and
while the other images are post contrast
and clearly in this case slightly know
whether it's signal-to-noise because of
course the time that is allotted for
each one of these images is less than it
was before and we could go on and on I
have another example with always a
cardiac phases about 20 temporal dynamic
frames so this are just some examples
here and now I can show you I would like
to show you some videos actually so I'm
gonna go ahead and show you the first
video which where basically I am showing
a one cardiac phase and over basically
the uptake of contrast announcement and
you can see in this case this is an
example with 20 dynamic frames
it's about deposition was still about 30
32 minutes so we about 1 minute and a
half per temporal dynamic which overall
will be considered pretty slow but you
know for the for imaging dynamically the
mouth of the crude is quite acceptable
and I'm going to go ahead and show you
another video instead of just one
temporal frame after a while after
contrast agent injection and in this
case the temporal frame is the same the
snapshot after contrast is the same but
I'm showing you here the scene images of
the aortic root cycling through the
different cardiac phases and in fact you
can see the article moving in this video
but you wouldn't see moving or moving
very little in the video that I showed
before
and lastly I'm showing you here an
example of dynamic curves obtained from
several mice in the our pic root
obtained with this approach that I just
described
compared to skeletal muscle which is
also in this interview skeletal muscle
as an aside is the tissue has typically
very permeability and in many cases is
taken as some sort of reference tissue
and you can clearly see that overall
enhancement in the aortic root is much
higher than the skeletal muscle
indicating higher permeability in this
territory with respect to muscle with
this example I would like to conclude
and I'm open to taking any questions you
may have
ok thank you dr. Kulkarni for your
informative presentation so if the
audience has a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
answer a question box located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
are there any possibilities for
acceleration thank you this is actually
an excellent question the answer is yes
and there are possibilities for
acceleration in the approach that I
described before and that this self
gated approach so I if you if you recall
and when I described the self gated
imaging of the Artic route I said that
the acquisition of case-based line
happens concede continuously and the
acquisition is intrinsically random so
to speak and by that I mean that that is
as I said before the chance that the
same case-based lines would be acquired
in the same exact
days during different cardiac cycles is
very low and that is due to the fact
that different cardiac cycles typically
differing lengths vary slightly but
enough to make this process sort of
intrinsically pseudo-random and these
kind of acquisitions are perfectly
suited for compressed sensing
reconstruction this is actually an
approach that has been applied by our
collaborators in Amsterdam to obtain
very fast scenic images of the
myocardium accelerated if I'm not
mistaken up to 90 times with respect to
what you could obtain without
acceleration and also using even answer
short te radial sequences for improved
scene imaging with less flow artifacts
of the heart so yes this is a this is a
possibility
okay another question here are there any
other vascular territories in the mouth
where it is useful to evaluate
endothelial permeability and thank you
yes so there is actually work has been
done also in the brachiocephalic artery
of the mouse and this is another
vascular territory where blacks develop
quite consistently in mouse models and
they are actually quite inflamed and
therefore this has been applied also the
investigation of endothelial
permeability has been applied also in
these cases and I have to say most of
these approaches actually I have used
slightly different techniques than the
ones that I have described based on Luke
Locker acquisitions actually for
quantitative t1 mapping and a slightly
different contrast agents the contrast
agent that I have described here is
extravascular extracellular and it's a
small contrast agent at least that's the
one that we've used in the examples that
I have shown that doesn't bind to
albumin in other cases other researchers
have used some contrast agents and
specifically bind to albumin and
extravasated slower than the one that I
showed here but a lot of work has been
done in this area also demonstrating how
these measures are sensitive not only to
black progression but to aggravation of
endothelial injury either with wire
injury like mechanical injury or by
using endothelial toxins just such as
there are some hypervenom but also
sensitive to changes after therapeutic
interventions for example we start in
Zoar - cycling so yes this is also an
active area
okay another question has self gated
imaging been used for this application
in other studies and yes actually it has
and for application that's another
application actually to the
brachiocephalic artery there are have
been some studies there and but only use
a not dynamic contrast enhance
Ammar as i showed here only using a
keyboard mapping actually with variable
flip angle with a similar pro approach
as i used but only post contrast and
after a fixed amount of time that is
suitable for imaging with I believe
albumin binding agents
okay so we have time for one more
question
how can DCE data be analyzed so that
that's a good question so I have
mentioned some approaches before during
the introduction in general and DCE data
especially in cancer where the technique
has been used extensively and analyzed
using modeling based approaches and if I
can go back to the slide that we have on
the background I think it would be
easier to show you so that you can see
here one of the most used kinetic models
that is actually employed typically to
analyze the CEA MRI data you can see as
I mentioned before several parameters
can be evaluated from this model it is
called a modified Tufts model the
fractional plasma volume in the tissue
of interest VP can be calculated ke
trans which is typically a measure of
flow permeability can be calculated and
ket the backflow of contrast agent from
the tissue to the plasma compartment can
also be typically calculated as you can
see to perform kinetic modeling two
inputs are well one input I'm sorry is
required that would be that's called CP
that's the contrast agent concentration
in this meeting vessel that would be the
sort of red and stripe here in our in my
schematics and but of course in order to
fit parameters we also need an
estimation of the concentration in the
tissue of interest that would be city so
if you recall I briefly mentioned that
many applications for vessel wall
imaging use black blood techniques that
willingly supply suppress the signal
from the blood plasma during acquisition
so that we can better see the vessel
wall
for practical purposes for DCE
MRI modeling this means that CP so an
estimation of the contrast agent
concentration of the blood plasma in the
blood plasma will not be available for
these kind of studies because we don't
have really signal from which to
estimated so several other approaches
can be taken as to meant to actually
analyze these data specifically as I
mentioned here on the right side we can
calculate area under the curve after
doing our best to convert em our signal
to contrast agent concentration in the
tissue of take slope time to peak and
there is also some other approaches that
are quite interesting those are called
relative modeling approaches and they
try to extract relative kinetic
parameters relative to other tissues I
mean for example using the muscle if you
recall in the very last slide I showed
you muscle curves as an example so for
example these scrubs could be used as
the basis for a lotof modeling to a
struct relative kinetic parameters of
permeability India of the Groot so I
think those are the main options
thank you doctor
no money and Todd Sasser now before we
go I would like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration additionally a short poll
will now pop up on your screen your
feedback is important to us thank you
for participating
so like again thank dr. Claudia Cal
Connie Amanda and Todd Shafter for their
time today we would also like to thank
lab roots and our sponsor Brooker for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through March 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thanks for joining us until next
time goodbye